la bière
vous connaissez non plus ancien breuvage
alcoolisé de l'humanité la bière est une
boisson fermentée à base de céréales
germées obtenues par fermentation grâce
à des levures transformant le sucre en
alcool c'était une question rhétorique
en fait donc la bière vous connaissez
bien évidemment vous avez sûrement
entendu plein de choses à son sujet et
aujourd'hui on va répondre à la question
suivante est-ce que la bière c'est bon
pour la santé
dangereux
[Musique]
donc on va passer en revue tout ce qu'on
entend dire et tout ce qu'on peut lire
sur la bière et la santé et on va
checker un peu tout ça mais surtout
restez bien jusqu'à la fin parce qu'il y
a un truc hyper important qui va au-delà
de tout ce qu'on va pouvoir se raconter
là et qu'il faut pas oublier vous verrez
la bière c'est bon pour la digestion
alors on entend dire principalement deux
trucs là-dessus d'abord la bière
faciliterait la vidange de l'estomac
bonne vidange c'est-à-dire qu'elle
permettrait à l'estomac de se vider plus
rapidement donc ça faciliterait la
digestion et ben il y a effectivement
une étude japonaise qui a isolé deux
composés présents dans la bière qui
améliorent ce qu'on appelle la motilité
gastro-intestinale donc la vidange de
l'estomac et la digestion ok donc il y a
deux trucs dans la bière qui favorisent
ça par contre dans la bière il y a aussi
un truc qui s'appelle l'alcool et
l'alcool va ça ralentit la vidange
gastrique au contraire surtout quand on
augmente les doses donc bon et l'alcool
ça donne aussi un max de boulot à notre
foi qui doit dans un premier temps
dégradé l'alcool et dans un deuxième
temps éliminer toutes les substances
toxiques que cette dégradation a créé du
coup le foie peut pas jouer correctement
son rôle dans la digestion on entend
dire aussi que la bière améliorait la
qualité de notre microbiote intestinal
c'est-à-dire toutes les bactéries les
champignons etc qu'on a dans les
intestins et qui participent à la
digestion bah là encore il y a une étude
qui a conclu que effectivement c'est le
cas si vous voulez tout savoir pour
déduire ça ils ont fait boire une bière
par jour à des gens puis ils ont comparé
les échantillons de leur caca avant et
après et ils ont constaté que la
diversité de leur microbiote était
meilleur après qu'avant mais ce que vous
lirez peut-être pas c'est que l'étude
elle recommande de boire de la bière
sans alcool vu qu'elle a exactement les
mêmes effets que la bière avec alcool et
qu'il faut quand même en boire tous les
jours mais ça on va y revenir à la fin
et puis selon une vaste étude
internationale menée sur plein de gens
qui se lacolent la bière s'abalonne et
sa full à chiasse donc on doit pouvoir
trouver mieux pour bien digérer la bière
c'est bon pour le cœur la bière ça
ferait baisser le mauvais cholestérol et
augmenter le bon ce qui aurait un effet
protecteur sur notre système
cardiovasculaire notre cœur est nos
vaisseaux alors là dessus on trouve tout
et son contraire certains disent que la
bière contient des stérols végétaux
c'est-à-dire des molécules auxquelles le
cholestérol va se lier ce qui va
permettre de l'éliminer plus facilement
et que ça bon on sait que c'est bon pour
le cœur d'autres répondent que ok il y a
des stérols mais pas assez pour que ça
aille en effet pour mettre tout le monde
d'accord une méta analyse de 84 études
différentes à démontré que la
consommation quotidienne modérée
d'alcool était lié à une diminution de
13 à 25% du risque de mourir d'une
maladie cardiovasculaire mais on a aussi
démontré que si on passe le cap d'une
consommation modérée on va y revenir bah
là le risque d'avoir des problèmes
cardiovasculaires il s'inverse et il
augmente très très rapidement et puis
bon là encore ça implique de boire de
l'alcool tous les jours et ça ça un nom
et ça comporte des risques mais on va en
reparler oui je tise oui enfin je fais
du teasing
[Musique]
la bière c'est bon pour les reins bon la
bière ça fait pisser personne peut dire
le contraire mais vous savez pourquoi on
en a déjà parlé mais ok je vous le redis
bah c'est parce que dans la bière il y a
de l'alcool que notre corps il repère
que c'est toxique et que du coup il nous
fait pisser plus pour éliminer tout ça
donc déjà la bière ça fait pisser mais
pas plus que la vodka c'est juste que un
verre de votre cas au bar je veux dire
c'est 3 cl alors qu'un verre de bière
c'est 25 cl il y a la même quantité
d'alcool dans les deux mais dans la
bière il y a plus de liquide et plus de
liquide plus de pis donc on retient quoi
bah que oui la bière elle fait tourner
nos reins mais c'est pour nous
débarrasser d'un truc toxique qu'elle
contient elle-même donc est-ce qu'on
peut vraiment dire que c'est bon pour la
santé la vérité c'est que oui il y a des
études qui ont démontré que l'effet
diurétique de la bière diurétique ça
veut dire que ça fait pisser que cet
effet diurétique il fait du bien Nora il
y en a une autre qui a conclu que la
bière ça favorise l'élimination des
résidus de calcium au niveau de nos
reins et que donc ça diminue le risque
de faire des calculs rénaux mais encore
une fois dans le cadre d'une
consommation modérée c'est à dire pas
plus d'un
sur le sujet apparemment les chercheurs
aiment bien la bière cette étude est là
conclut notamment que c'est le houblon
qui pourrait avoir un effet bénéfique le
houblon seulement parce qu'en pratique
on sait très bien que l'alcool ça abîme
les nerfs les neurones etc et que ça
peut provoquer tout un tas de maladies
neurologiques il y a même une étude qui
a démontré qu'il y a pas de consommation
d'alcool même modéré qui n'abîment pas
le cerveau donc on peut sûrement trouver
mieux en matière de prévention de la
maladie d'Alzheimer la bière c'est bon
pour le moral
boire une petite bière c'est vrai que ça
détend après le boulot en terrasse avec
les potes bon c'est frais ça fait du
bien c'est une petite euphorie qui monte
on est bien qui peut dire le contraire
bon après c'est vrai que ça marche aussi
avec n'importe quel autre boisson sans
alcool c'est surtout le moment qui est
cool mais ok c'est vrai qu'avec la bière
il y a la petite euphorie en plus puis
bon si on aime bien ça bah c'est
toujours agréable de se faire plaisir
après bon là on parle d'un truc modéré
et à court terme et pas trop régulier
parce que j'imagine qu'il y en a
certains d'entre vous qui savent très
bien ce que c'est que la déprime d'un
lendemain de cuite et sur le long terme
de manière régulière on sait que
l'alcool ça peut provoquer ou aggraver
une dépression pour dire les choses
autrement c'est vrai que l'alcool ça a
un effet anxiolytique c'est à dire que
ça endort l'angoisse et l'anxiété sur le
moment mais ça a pas d'effet
anti-dépresseurs c'est même le contraire
alors on dit aussi que ça aide à mieux
dormir donc à se sentir bien on en a
déjà parlé dans ma vidéo sur les
bullshit sur le sommeil l'alcool ça aide
à s'endormir ok mais ça perturbe les
rythmes du sommeil donc on a un sommeil
de mauvaise qualité et au final on se
réveille en moins bonne forme donc une
petite bière ou deux de temps en temps
si on aime ça ça fait plaisir mais sur
le long terme on peut pas dire que ce
soit bon pour le moral l'alcool ça crée
toujours plus de problèmes que ça n'en
résout dans la mesure où ça n'en
résoudre jamais aucun boire de la bière
après le sport ça aide à mieux récupérer
alors je veux pas mentir j'ai moi-même
expérimenté cette technique pas
tellement pour la science c'est juste
que j'ai longtemps joué au rugby de mon
expérience personnelle je peux vous
assurer qu'après une troisième mi-temps
ça m'est arrivé plus d'une fois d'être
éveillé par des crampes bien vénères bah
oui parce que vous souvenez de ce que
j'ai dit sur la bière et les reins
l'alcool ça fait pisser plus de liquide
qu'on en boit du coup le corps il va
piocher dans nos réserves d'eau celle
qu'on a dans nos cellules celle de notre
cerveau c'est en partie pour ça qu'on a
mal à la tête quand on boit trop celle
de nos muscles etc donc au final ça
déshydrate et la déshydratation c'est la
meilleure amie des crampes donc après un
effort physique qui nous a déjà fait
perdre beaucoup d'eau se réhydrater avec
un liquide qui nous en fait perdre
encore plus ça peut être une bonne idée
pour récupérer de l'eau c'est bien c'est
très bien même et puis les et les
minéraux qu'il y a dans la bière vous
inquiétez pas vous les trouverez très
facilement ailleurs la bière ça renforce
les eaux la bière ça contiendrait du
silicium et ça ça renforcerait les os et
les articulations bon déjà mais bon
admettons commencez à connaître le
principe il y a effectivement une étude
qui conclut qui a beaucoup de silicium
dans la bière et une autre qui conclut
que ça un effet positif sur les autres
sauf qu'en vrai une alimentation
équilibrée ça couvre déjà largement nos
besoins quotidiens en silicium et qu'en
fait ça sert à rien d'en prendre plus
parce que tout ce qu'on prend en trop
c'est directement éliminé dans notre
urine mais bon admettons donc c'est bon
la bière c'est bon pour les eaux bah on
pourrait vous répondre que ok le
silicium mais l'alcool par contre ça
augmente le risque d'ostéoporose et
fractures toujours ce oui mais non en
fait et puis surtout voilà le genre de
truc qu'on peut lire boire une bière par
jour suffirait pour faire apparaître les
premiers effets donc pour être en bonne
santé il faut boire tous les jours c'est
ça boire une bière par jour c'est bon
pour la santé et ben non voilà je vous
depuis le début ce coup là on y est
c'est bien ça le problème parce que ok
la bière ça contient un des céréales des
vitamines des minéraux des levures etc
etc mais elle contient aussi pas mal de
sucre déjà moins que certaines autres
boissons alcoolisées mais quand même et
puis surtout bah elle contient de
l'alcool et boire de l'alcool tous les
jours même si c'est une seule bière bah
c'est pas ok alors là je sens que ça va
aller vous pouvez gueuler tant que vous
voulez dans les commentaires ou me
traiter de qui se communent de bouffeur
de concombre ça changera pas grand chose
je suis pas tellement fan des concombres
en plus je préfère largement la bière
mais bon c'est pas le sujet la question
c'est est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu
parler de la notion de consommation
raisonnable d'alcool c'est vrai que
alcool est raisonnable dans la même
phrase on n'est pas forcément habitué
pas une consommation raisonnable
d'alcool c'est le fait de boire de
l'alcool en limitant au maximum les deux
risques principaux les problèmes de
santé comme le cancer les maladies
cardiovasculaires ou neurologiques etc
et l'addiction est tout ce qui en
découle en termes d'impact psy logique
et sociale pour la personne concernée et
aussi pour tout son entourage c'est
prendre un risque acceptable si vous
voulez mais il faut bien reconnaître que
c'est une notion qui a pas mal bougé
avec le temps et puis la bière ce n'est
pas mauvais pour la santé à condition
d'être raisonnable bien sûr le Comité
national de défense contre l'alcoolisme
dit même qu'on peut en boire jusqu'à 1
litre et demi sans danger pour la santé
cela fait quand même 6 bonnes Shop et de
quoi se désaltérer dans une journée pour
être très clair et très concret depuis
2017 une consommation raisonnable
d'alcool c'est divers maximum par
semaine pas plus de deux verres par jour
et pas tous les jours alors admettons
que vous buviez une bière tous les jours
ok ça a des effets négatifs sur la santé
il y a plein de trucs qu'on fait qu'on
les ai fait négatifs sur la santé donc
bon c'est quand même pas bien méchant
c'est quoi le problème en fait et ben le
risque quand on voit tous les jours
c'est de perdre le contrôle de sa
consommation et de glisser tout
doucement sans s'en rendre compte vers
l'addiction déjà si vraiment on a besoin
de sa petite bière tous les jours il
faut se poser des questions et puis il y
a aussi un truc dont il faut se méfier
c'est ce qu'on appelle le phénomène de
tolérance c'est un phénomène qui est
très connu et qui fait qu'au bout d'un
certain temps quand on prend une
substance très régulièrement voir tous
les jours notre corps est fini par
s'habituer et les effets de cette
substance il diminue donc on doit
augmenter les doses pour avoir les mêmes
effets qu'avant donc oui dans l'absolu
en théorie tout ce qu'on vient de voir
là sur les effets bénéfiques de la bière
sur la santé ça peut se défendre sauf
que bon non seulement ça implique d'en
boire trop régulièrement voir
quotidiennement mais en plus tous les
bénéfices de la bière vous pouvez les
avoir avec d'autres produits qui
contiennent pas d'alcool et en réalité
les effets positifs de ce que contient
la bière ils sont largement
contrebalancés par les effets négatifs
de l'alcool qui sont bien pire
d'ailleurs même le centre d'information
scientifique sur la bière oui ça existe
recommande je cite une consommation
responsable et modérée en toute
circonstance autant dire une
consommation raisonnable d'alcool et
maintenant vous savez ce que ça veut
dire alors attention ne faites pas dire
ce que j'ai pas dit moi j'aime bien ça
la bière ça m'arrive régulièrement d'en
boire un verre ou deux
ou plus donc je vous dis pas qu'il faut
surtout pas en boire qu'on soit bien
clair d'ailleurs je vous dis jamais ce
que vous devez faire moi je vous donne
juste des infos pour que vous puissiez
décider de ce que vous allez faire en
l'occurrence buvez de la bière si vous
aimez ça pensez juste peut-être à faire
un point régulièrement sur votre
consommation pour être sûr qu'elle ne
vient pas problématique donc faites ce
que vous voulez mais en tout cas ne vous
laissez pas avoir par les gens qui vous
racontent que c'est bon pour la santé ce
genre de discours là entre déni et
arguments marketing ça fait beaucoup de
mal déjà par le passé voilà DTC c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici
là prenez soin de vous et prenez soin
des autres mettez-vous bien et surtout
portez-vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]